for the third time in a little over a
month ambulance staff readied themselves
for a day of strike action
thousands of members of three separate
unions walking off the job across much
of England and Wales the demand a pay
award that keeps Pace with a rising cost
of living the message that the service
is already stretched Beyond its limit
you know people wait several hours for
ambulances every single day when we're
not on strike so it's not any different
today than it is any other day
unfortunately and that's the thing
that's got to change that's the reason
why we're striking due to the mom that's
quite being placed a movie delayed
Mondays are typically the busiest day
for ambulance services across the
country with temperatures in many areas
well below zero as the day began the
message was to keep emergency 999 lines
as clear as possible we know when it
gets cold that the number of 999 calls
go up they go up appropriately because
people who've got certain clinical
conditions do do suffer more in the cold
the public can really help us out by
only phoning 999 when it is a life in
them emergency
on a picket line in London managers were
coordinating with striking Crews
dispatching them when emergency calls
did come in but the message was even
serious incidents would face substantial
delays less serious ones could expect no
ambulance cover at all
the intensification of this strike
action looks set to be maintained with
another 11 strikes planned over the next
two months the biggest single day of
action likely to be the 6th of February
when Mercers will join these striking
paramedics
the unions insist the solution is in the
government's hands a pay increase of
around 10 percent Rishi soon is the core
decision maker he needs to come back to
the negotiating table get this sorted
out he's the leader of the country so
these people can go back to work
Britain's prime minister was visiting a
mental health unit in the northwest of
England on Monday his government says
it's working to negotiate a pay
settlement for the next financial year
while investing in providing services
like those for mental health
we will provide more mental health
ambulances more crisis centers that are
based in communities more mental health
professionals engage with 111 all of
that will give people the care that they
need and crucially will also relieve
some of the pressure that we see in a e
departments
but in the short term that pressure on
emergency provision is only likely to
increase with knock-on postponement to
schedule treatments too as health
workers vow to continue their industrial
action Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera London